ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
coffee zilla we're talking today about
how aiden ross lied about his milf token
scam but before we get into that let me
just say thank you guys so much for all
the support
on the save the kids investigation it
was our biggest investigation ever
uh i'm exhausted full disclosure i've
like slept the last 48 hours
but um we're back back in the saddle
gonna get some easier investigations
some low-hanging fruit here
some easy stuff before we ramp up our
next big investigation i know you guys
like more regular content i try to get
that out to you on those bigger
investigations it's a little harder to
be consistent but thank you to all our
new subscribers we've got a lot more
content coming for you soon
and let me say dude the channel like
doubled in size
in a month which is completely insane
and i never thought it would be possible
but it might be this year
that we get to open the one million
subscriber
secret door
we got a big surprise there um and i
didn't think we'd be able to get to it
but it might be
this year so pump the stock pumpzilla
guys you know what to do
you can pump it by subscribing the
dividends have been amazing this month
let me tell you
early zillow holders very happy very
happy with
what's been going on without further ado
though let's get into our our little
investigation here
into sort of the laughing stock of the
internet lately which is
aiden ross let's go to the board i'll
explain
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million studio i'm your host coffee
zilla
and of course we're talking about aiden
ross popular twitch streamer one of the
the biggest right now and he got in hot
water recently after promoting a token
called
milf token i wasn't able to talk about
it at the time because i was doing the
save the kids stuff
but i want to revisit it a little bit
because he's been lying to the internet
about his scam saying it wasn't a scam
no one got hurt
and that's a complete lie he lied to
h3h3 he lied to
hassan well it depends actually how you
look at it he might have um
you you might say he's too dumb to
understand what he
really did so that's the two options
actually that's the real two options
he either maliciously lied or
he's accidentally lying because he
doesn't understand how crypto scams
work let's find out together you guys
tell me what you think do you think this
was a malicious lie
or a purposeful one let's check it out
all right bringing down the board uh we
got aidan ross here this was the
stream that sparked it all he said that
he was gonna
on may uh 26th i believe he said he was
going to be buying
milf token this is a paid endorsement
um but uh yeah let me uh let me go ahead
and buy let me buy a milf
real quick i want to buy one um
he spends the next like 15 to 30 minutes
trying to figure out how uniswap works
and he's on the phone with what sounds
like jordan galen
guys if you guys remember him from the
save the kids investigation
now it's important to note that aiden
ross looks like he got paid around 186
000
this was a payment to jordan galen who
helped
aiden ross facilitate this whole
transaction we know that he was running
deals for a lot of these guys
so about two hundred thousand dollars
was paid to aiden ross and people
understandably were upset when later
aiden said he basically
knew it was a scam by the way that milk
token did a while back
i already told you guys don't buy that i
got paid a bag do that
like i don't give up how many guys
actually bought it i hope none of you
guys
actually bought the scamp token that i
promoted
hashtag not financial advice hashtag
life of an influencer
aiden ross hashtag w so anyways he goes
on to be confronted about it this is all
an old news to some of you we're just
catching you up because i'm gonna show
you
how he's been lying um he gets he gets
called
out by h3h3 and hassan
they get him on a call and they confront
him about these facts
it wasn't a pump and dump i wanted to
show you this clip from my live stream
this is my promo i just want to say real
quick they
wish that they never did this with me
let me just show you why
i'm
so his response is they wish they had
never done it with me guys
because look i said i'm not a financial
advisor i said i'm getting paid for this
therefore they wish they had never done
it it couldn't have been a pump and dump
which that's fine but then the lie comes
when he says this
they wish they never doubted me right so
because like they were just like what
the hell was that
so let's see like if i was a brand and i
paid somebody to do that i just did it
horribly i didn't know what i was doing
i did the scam horribly i didn't promote
it right so therefore
it wasn't a scam and this is the whole
framing he sets up dude it was a bad
promo
they wish they had never done it with me
it couldn't have been a scam because of
that
and he harps on this over and over and
over for why he's innocent
you know my like i just want people to
understand like
it was a really really bad promo that's
what makes him
innocent the fact that hey because it's
a bad promo clearly
no one bought in and he continues this
thought
later i saw it yeah in the beginning
hassan you you
pay attention to all analytics you i
know you were on that i used to watch
you when back when the election was
going on bro you pay attention to every
statistic at every minute of the day you
saw that after that
it went down so listen it was not a scam
of pumping up nothing
that's the reason it wasn't a scam guys
because the price went down
after he promoted it in other words had
people lost money
it would have been a scam it would have
been a pump and dump but because the
price went down it wasn't a pump and
dump
now this is where the key lie is guys
we're not going to let them get away
with this
because this is the biggest lie
influencers love to harp on they love to
defend themselves they go hey the price
the price didn't spike and then dump
it wasn't a scam guys so we're going to
go forward with the premise
that if people lost money it was a scam
but if it was
truly such a bad promo we won't blame
aiden ross so let's find out
let's dig into the details of crypto
scams and find out
did aiden ross cause more people to lose
money
all right guys so here i've prepared a
little presentation for you guys on how
crypto scams work because we have to
understand some things before we
evaluate
how well or bad aiden ross's promotion
was because people don't understand how
cryptos games work they think
people think price is everything but the
problem is it's
not see if you looked at the milf token
market cap
you would see this here's where aiden
ross promoted around may 27th right here
and the price actually really
fell so if you thought price was
everything then aiden ross's point
makes sense price was high earlier and
then aiden ross promotes and the price
nothing really happens
but the truth is that's not what makes a
crypto a scam
actually it almost has nothing to do
with it it's nice to have a high price
but
the real problem with scam coins is
finding a buyer
okay here's an example we have a sample
problem in front of us let's say you
have 10 million
scam ross tokens okay hypothetical token
i just made up
let's say each are priced at a dollar i
own 10 million of them
uh does that mean i have 10 million
dollars well the answer is
obviously no because unless someone buys
them and actually
pays a dollar on the market it doesn't
mean anything and so you can't sell like
let's say i'm the owner of this
i can't sell my scam ross tokens if the
volume of the coin
is low if there's not a lot of people
trading it back and forth like let's say
only one token gets traded
you know a day it would take me 10
million days to offload these tokens so
it's basically worthless the truth is
that trading volume
is the king for scam coins in order to
offload
your money and actually realize those
gains to actually scam people
you need high volume okay in other words
you need enough buyers
to buy up those 10 million scam ross
tokens i hope we're all on the same page
here
on how it works if i just dump 10
million coins into the market
the price is gonna collapse and no one's
gonna buy it up right so you have to
have
enough buyers so the question is how do
you get new buyers i'm sorry this is
like a it's like a blockchain
presentation here guys
i said i'd be doing easier
investigations i don't know why i'm
doing a thing but yeah
the question how do we get new buyers
and the answer is this guy
aka just just influencers you you buy
influencers guys buying influencers
means more volume
more volume means that the people who
hold the tokens the scammers
okay the people who invented these
tokens yesterday can then sell it off
today
right this is how these things work and
to be clear milf token's like a dead
coin it's dead
all the all of aiden's viewers who
bought it they have like it's worth
nothing now
so let's check the truth because now
that we know price doesn't really matter
now we can check
if the promotion actually worked so
let's take a look at the volume data
i've put it here this is from the
blockchain blockchain doesn't lie people
we all know this so on may 22nd may 23rd
this is all leading up to the promotion
the volume is pretty stable at a 24 hour
volume of about
a million dollars being traded sometimes
less sometimes more
so what do you think it's worth to have
aiden ross promote your coin
we know they paid him about two hundred
thousand dollars to promote
the coin let's take a look at the next
day and i did the did you the favor of
putting it into a bar
chart we're getting fancy around here uh
yeah
turns out it was pretty good guys the
day of aiden ross's promo
the bad promo bro hey it was a bad promo
they got 19 million dollars in 24 hour
volume
19 million dollars probably half of
that's buy half of that sell roughly
since the price stayed roughly the same
so let's say we've got nine million
dollars in sell orders taking place that
day
somebody offloaded nine million dollars
onto who's the new buyers aiden ross's
fans now aiden ross says that uh
everything's fine because you know how
could it be a scam if he
he got paid in u.s dollars right well
let's take a look at
at the efficiency of that spending for
the milf token right
how efficient is it to buy stupid
influencers
and greedy influencers for your coin
well let's take a look i
put aidan ross's cost to promote
against the volume so you got this much
volume
19 million dollars in exchange for 200
000 it's about an extra 15 16 17 million
dollars in trading volume
all for 200 000 i'd call that a good
deal i don't know what do you guys think
you call that a good deal
and what would you call the guy who
promotes this stuff what would you what
would you title that
because i can't believe people are
letting him get away with this lie
that it was a bad promo bro hassan you
pay attention to the analytics bro
you pay attention to all analytics you i
know you were on that i used to watch
you when
back when the election was going on bro
you pay attention to every
statistic at every minute of the day you
saw that after that
it went down it was not a scam of
pumping up nothing
actually aiden i do pay attention to all
the analytics
and um yeah turns out it was a scam it
was a pump and dump now
you may not have been the person selling
the tokens you may have just gotten paid
200 000
flat rate but uh somebody pumped and
dumped thanks to you
i mean without you we couldn't have seen
these kind of numbers right
so your fans got scammed because you're
a scumbag influencer who sells out your
fans for two hundred thousand dollars
in exchange for 15 million dollars
roughly in extra volume and so that
is a scam period it is a puff and up you
may try to hide behind the fact
you only got paid 200 000 flat rate but
try telling that to your
fans who lost money i'm really so sick
of these people trying to get away with
this stuff saying i did a bad promotion
bro it's a pretty good promotion if you
ask me
high roi here so conclusion well
aiden ross did scam his fans he ran a
pump and dump that
other people benefited from while he
made a flat 200 000
and he potentially made milf scammers
millions
and i gotta say as a disclaimer though
aiden ross to be clear
wasn't the only one who made money that
day right some
others familiar faces made money off the
milf promotions too
um for example i'll show you guys real
quick as we end this
this one influencer who made about 128
000
according to blockchain selling milf
tokens for promoting it as well
check it out you guys know i've been
investing in a lot of cryptocurrency
lately and one coin
recently that came up i actually saw
from jake paul as well
it's called milf it's insane guys i 25 x
my investment which is just nuts but
this is a dope coin guys definitely
swipe up and check it out
[Music]
milf
[Music]
somehow you ain't say much what a waster
someone with their fame up you took from
everyone including all your day ones
i can't believe it still the truth you
need a spill you proof the greed is
real you can't delete it chill from the
start it was doomed
i heard